Peter King NBC sports.com the NFL
columnist sand football morning in
America good morning Pete how are you
hey Dan how are you I'm doing okay no
complaints here
any thoughts on pushing back the drafter
you think it's full speed ahead I know
they're gonna do the draft they've gone
too far to push it back and I also think
because they're going to have this you
know as I wrote yesterday in my column
there's going to be a telethon element
associated with this draft so I think
they're going to sort of combine this
telethon for kovat 19 relief along with
the draft and do it that way but no I
don't see them pushing it back then well
help me understand that telethon part of
this are we gonna have marquee players
answering phone calls yeah you know that
I don't know that I don't know I think
it'll probably mostly online but who
knows okay maybe they will have a phone
bank of people but the one the one thing
I do know about it is I think it's going
to have players coaches and a lot of
former players involved you know the NFL
I do know this is is because it's going
to be a weird year to get players
involved in this the NFL has already
arranged to send out 50 little portable
cameras that players will set up to
basically record themselves I think
getting calls from from general managers
and coaches and all that when they're
picked so that is going to be part of
this it's and it's all going to be weird
the fact that that you know as I
reported NFL Network in ESPN are likely
to be doing a combined telecast you know
you know cats and dogs working together
they're a little bit you know Rich Eisen
Trey Wingo and Daniel Jeremiah and and
and and all the ESPN guys you know
kuiper and all those guys so it's all
going to be very different this year
there'll be a 30 for 30 on this draft
one day that's what Chris Ballard the
Colts general manager said to me yeah
honestly he said yeah they're gonna do a
30-30 on this trap be fascinating but
you start to look at this and being a I
do the draft if everybody can do their
job leading up to the draft at that did
you know I don't want to force this into
you know hey we're gonna hold the draft
no matter what it you know is everybody
gonna be able to do what they would
normally do or come close it yeah see I
don't I mean how would you like to be
the team that is picking two atong of a
lower in this draft
not only did to have three injuries
significant injuries in his last 13
months of playing football to ankles one
hip but now no team doctor can you know
let's say it's the Dolphins let's say
who the team that's been linked to him
mostly the Dolphins want to pick him so
your team doctor and your orthopedist
normally on a player like that he would
spend a day with the Dolphins doctors
and medical staff go they'd be going
over everything he'd be spending half a
day you know sitting with Chan Gailey
and and they and the coaching staff
obviously Brian Flores they can't do any
of that
yeah they can be on a zoom video
conference or FaceTime with him for an
hour you know and and so this is Dan I
you know Mike Tannenbaum said last week
he's not to be responsible for any team
to pick two in the top ten I'm not sure
I'd go that far but you're putting your
your career on the line basically if you
pick a guy with a significant injury
history because of that injury history
flares up again all of a sudden you're
going to be the village idiot yeah and I
wonder if all of a sudden Justin Herbert
becomes more
tracted to the dolphins yeah because he
checks all the boxes here he's healthy
and he's these injuries follow these
players when they go from college to the
pros we've seen this you know Sam
Bradford like a lot of these guys the
injury trail continues and that might
scare off the Dolphins if you're gonna
be picking that high and looking for a
franchise quarterback yeah I mean you
just don't know the key though the good
thing for the Dolphins quite honestly is
when you have Ryan Fitzpatrick you know
you've got a guy who's good enough to
handle it for a year if he has to and
look I don't care what quarterback he
picked if he's got the most pristine
medical exam of any player in history
you know I can you imagine Joe burrow
without any offseason program other than
one that he is staring at his laptop you
know doing it that way and and and then
maybe having a very abbreviated training
camp imagine him playing opening day if
there is an opening day I mean it's
that's one of the reasons why I mean
I've my operating series I don't
necessarily think it's any guarantee the
Bengals are getting rid of me Andy doll
why would you you know you might need
him yeah I wondered about that too that
it might make sense and certainly if I'm
drafting to uh I'm not looking at you
know playing to in that first year
like I would I would use caution with
him and if you have Ryan Fitzpatrick
that's why you kept him I would just say
you're our quarterback too uh we're
gonna bring him along as slowly as
possible and you don't have to kind of
throw them in there and say all right
sink or swim for this team but we're
talking to Peter King from NBC Sports
and of course football morning in
America where's the commissioner going
to be on draft nights I'd be surprised
now if he wasn't in his house in
Bronxville New York doing the picks from
there I mean if you're asking every one
of your employees you're asking Chris
Greer of the Miami Dolphins to have
three first-round picks this will be the
biggest night of Chris Greer's executive
career and he's got to do it alone
sitting in his house being connected by
zoom or WebEx or whatever
they use to end to all other employees
on the Dolphins you're asking all these
people to do this stuff from their homes
and you're not in your house it looked
not too good I think I think Roger
Goodell is going to have to have his
little camera set up in his house which
is the easiest thing in the world half
the free world if you if you watch any
News Network now you see all these
people hey they look pretty good on
their on their remote camera that's
because everybody's got what basically
got what Peter King has he's got a spare
room in his apartment in Brooklyn and
they can NBC came in and set up a camera
so when I'm on TV it looks like there's
a great setup there and it's and it's
fine so I would be I'd be surprised now
if Roger Goodell wasn't in his house I
don't know anything but that is that
would be my strong recommendation and by
the way as I wrote yesterday my column I
can tell you that there are TV people
who really want Roger Goodell in his
house because that's setting an example
for the rest of America quite honestly
yeah that's a good point I still don't
understand why the Panthers got rid of
Cam Newton or the way they got rid of
Cam Newton is there any other
information about this it just seems
like there's some unanswered questions
there
well I'll try to read the tea leaves
even though obviously this has been a
very well guarded secret it's no secret
that Cam Newton wanted some sort of
commitment he said so and either an
Instagram or Twitter post that he wanted
a commitment from the Panthers so this
is a team that's got a new coach who's
probably never barely met cam in his
life I got a new offensive coordinator
Oh comes from the same school I was 30
or 31 years old he's a young guy they're
trying to build something for the long
haul then I the only way I would not
have given Cam Newton a contract
extension in Carolina because I don't
know what he is right now the last year
and a half he's not been Cam Newton he's
been injured
so I would really want to see him and
I'd want to see if he worked in whatever
offense we were gonna run so just my gut
feeling
I think that they probably said we'd
rather get a quarterback to build with
for the long haul who health wise and in
our scheme were comfortable with
ergo teddy bridgewater yeah that but I I
guess Cam Newton is healthy though
didn't he get him did he get medical
clearance here yes but even last year at
the start of training camp go back to
what he told me late last July and that
is that he was learning how to be a
different quarterback you know he had
great respect for guys like Peyton
Manning and stuff kind of reinvented
themselves with maybe a lesser arm late
in their careers and so he talked to me
openly about being kind of being a
different player and welcoming you know
playing the position maybe a little bit
differently not putting himself in
harm's way as much so I again I don't
doubt that he's healthy but you know in
my opinion being healthy and being
handed 150 million bucks over five years
are two different things
i I don't dan I don't know what Cam
Newton is right now yeah if he's gonna
be a pocket passer then I don't want him
if he has that ability to be anywhere
near what he once was then I could see
the fascination there or curiosity but I
was just curious about you know Cody
could he have stayed there I don't I
don't know I don't think any of us know
and the other problem is Dan when are
you going to be able to see yeah Cam
Newton when is I mean when it's Matt
rule gonna be able to run them through
drills today when August yeah so it's
all this is all such a mystery I don't I
don't blame the Panthers I don't blame
anybody I mean they got a new coach they
gotta set themselves up for the long
haul I don't blame them that they're not
that they don't want to get married to
Cam Newton before they even go out on a
date I saw where hard knocks is looking
at both the Rams and the Chargers if
they're able to have a train
camp on time what do you know I I don't
know a damn thing about and you know
what I just got to tell you this
I wrote eleven thousand four hundred and
fifty five words yesterday okay
and there are ten things that I didn't
talk about didn't discuss that I could
have I mean there is more happening now
in the NFL then there is in a heavy
regular-season week it's just it's
insane there's nothing at all all these
sports talk shows all your shows
honestly I hate to say it because it's
great for the NFL I'm not trying to show
farm but it should be all NFL all the
time well that baseball in Mart in Bay
in Arizona that'll be weird four and a
half months of every baseball game in
Surprise Arizona I don't know it's
that's a pretty weird thing to so yeah
you're allowed to talk about that too
but there's is there's an awful lot
going on in the NFL and I look hard
knocks is about the 440th thing on my
mind but I will say this if I were hard
knocks I'd pick a team right now and I
would start the cameras rolling I mean I
wrote yesterday in my column you know I
followed the Indianapolis Colts
basically last week virtually you know
Chris Ballard is is having zoom meetings
with 19 Scouts from his basement and and
you know with Scouts all over the
country spread out because they can't
meet personally this is an incredibly
fascinating time in NFL history
I mean all of it is so neat and this
draft is going to be incredibly
interesting how it comes out how it
comes off whether the NFL ends up giving
people more time for their picks
how trades get worked out it's just I
just think the whole time is fascinating
Peter thank you thank you for being
Peter King take care Peter King football
morning in America